how does a great title with so many good
ideas go so wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
journey to the center of the TARDIS we
continue through the re-watch and the
overdue Doctor Who reviews
huh this one was frustrating this is
another one that I hadn't really
rewatched in a long time largely because
I never felt the need to go back and
re-watch it I tell you man it's a
frustrating viewing because first of all
like I said at the intro awesome title
cool core concept a lot of neat and
ciliary concepts to go along with it and
for about the first half that's holding
together okay but then it just keeps
going directions that do not work at all
it's always kind of funny when you're
dealing with something whether it's an
episode of Doctor Who or an episode of
anything or a movie where it doesn't
work and you have to try and figure out
is it the core concept that doesn't work
is it the execution that doesn't work
was it just a bad idea from the start or
did they screw it up here it's kind of
both there are good ideas at the start
but they have to share space with back
ideas and the good ideas are well
executed the bad ideas maybe are
executed decently but they were bad
ideas in the first place so it doesn't
matter huh okay so this is the one where
car and the doctor get basically scooped
up by this salvage team who then are
hoping to salvage the TARDIS because the
doctor was trying to show Clara how to
fly it he had some of the system's
turned off including the shielding that
would have protected them from that but
now the TARDIS the TARDIS is in a mess
of a shape Clara's lost somewhere inside
the doctor has basically strong-armed
the salvage team into trying to help him
find her in this enormous potentially
infinite space while at the same time
they very much just want to start
stripping it for parts so honestly
core concept really solid like just the
opportunity to see more of the interior
of the TARDIS that's cool in and of
itself the idea of having pretty much
the whole you know the vast majority of
its set within that and we don't know
where it's going and the nature of the
engines and how the thing works if it's
breaking down lots of weirdness can
start happening things can start
reshaping it can start behaving
defensively because the guys who want to
break it down for scrap time starts
leaking both the past and the future
start bleeding in with what's going on
these are all really cool core concepts
so how do they screw all this up well
like I said it takes until about halfway
through for the cracks to start forming
and the first is with the monsters
so this has happened in a couple of
instances of Doctor Who I feel like
often til my head this might be the most
egregious there are some stories that
don't need a monster and sometimes when
the story doesn't need a monster but
they put it in there it's like I do okay
I guess it's just kind of there you know
I think of things like honestly kind of
a snowmen the snowmen themselves weren't
really needed I guess except that it
kind of alerted the doctor to start
looking and card to start looking into
things but you know something like that
the monsters don't add anything here the
monsters are an active distraction there
is no need for a creature in the story
at all and it's something that I wish
doctor who would realize it does not
have to be a monster of the week show it
can be at times and that's fine and
obviously they have a very good effects
and costumes and props team to bring
these things to life but there is no
reason for there to be creatures in this
story at all there are plenty of hazards
as it is and far more creative ones then
just monster like all the hazards
involved in the fact that time is being
weird and the spatial relationships of
rooms aren't behaving properly that is a
way more creative and interesting hazard
than just hmm monsters and
the reveal of what they are is also kind
of dumb like I get it insofar as like
sort of the radiation of stuff like
burns them and like misshapes them or
whatever we don't really get an
explanation for why they start attacking
their past selves I suppose you take it
for you're supposed to take it for
granted that their minds have either
broken down or they're so and so much
pain and anger that they're just lashing
out but not even that kind of token
explanation is given I think it's just
kind of presumed well they look
monstrous they will behave like monsters
why and so that whole thing is really
dominant it drags it drags the thing
down now that's not the only thing that
drags this thing down but it's a big
part of it because there's no reason for
these things to be there at all
so they don't help next up we have the
pointless twist doctor who has a lot of
potential for twists both in the grander
narrative when we're talking about
usually things like them whatever the
mystery box series element is or within
individual stories but much like no
monster of the week you don't always
need a twist and Doctor Who I don't
think obligatory inserts a twist to the
degree that they often insert a monster
of the week but there are some instances
where there's no need for there to be a
twist at all much less that twist and
this is probably the best embodiment of
that because we have this so the salvage
team it's these three guys two brothers
and an Android or at least what is
claimed to be an Android and what we
find out is that it's actually their
youngest brother who had his mind white
and they reset him to think he was an
Android that's not for the fact that
that's just both horrifying and really
stupid it also adds zero we don't have a
ton of event of investment into these
three they are they are borderline
ancillary to the story anyways they
their presence overall does work because
that's an additional complication for
the doctor because he needs the extra
hands he needs to help but he stuck with
help that he can't trust so their
presence being there in the first place
that works but we don't have enough
investment or time spent with them or
reason to care about them that we would
care about a twist like this and it's
borderline nonsensical like why would
anybody do that and the explanations
given are really flimsy and that kind of
twist has no connection to anything else
going on it's not like this sense of
identity or forgetting yourself is an
actual theme running through the episode
one could try and argue that maybe it
links to Clara in the fact that she
doesn't remember her past lives but we
don't know enough about how that's
working to call that a thematic through
line that's just been an ongoing element
for the past few episodes and this
doesn't play off that worth a day that's
a very tenuous connection it's the only
thing I can think of there's no reason
for this twist to exist at all and it
adds again nothing there's no reason for
this and it just eats up time again
there are some other things that I like
I do like that the solution involves the
sort of the time leakage and the the
logistical sequential bending of time I
also kind of like that it's big friendly
button that fixes everything is that
kind of a cheap and a bit of a lampshade
hanging on a day sex marketing yeah a
little bit but honestly it's the kind of
thing that works for me so I'm fine with
that
and even in regards to Clara what's
going on with there what little progress
is made in terms of her the impossible
girl mystery and the rest of it doesn't
matter because nobody remembers that
gets established firmly by the doctor at
the end of it that Clara is not gonna
remember this conversation where the
doctor has explained to her that he's
seen her repeatedly die so what in the
grander scheme stepping outside the
specific episode in the grander scheme
what's the point of him telling her that
at all she won't remember so it's a big
reveal from him to her that will
not affect her as a character yet it
won't affect her story yet because she's
not gonna remember and it's not even
like with the doctor and Donna where he
has to make the conscious choice to wipe
her memory so that that pains him to
have to do
it's not even in case of that he's
wiping out this timeline because they
died in it so it doesn't even have that
going for it so the entire thing is
pointless the doctor effectively learns
nothing as well the audience doesn't
really like it it's very odd to me how
big a revelation and they think did this
in hide as well like they try to make it
a big revelation that Clara is an
ordinary person that's it's hard to sell
that as a big she's just a person whoa
yeah everything we've seen about her
indicates that except for the time to
storm in the fact that you've seen her
die before nothing else has indicated
that she is anything special so just
reiterating that she's a normal ordinary
girl all that does is leave us right
where we were when we started this
entire thing because by all appearances
she was an ordinary girl but we know
something's wrong because we've seen her
in both the future of the past in than
those times died but she appears to be
an RA an ordinary girl well that gets
reaffirmed in Hyde and now we reaffirmed
here why establish it once fine I'll
actually let it pass and hide to have
somebody other than the doctor who has
established some degree of authority to
be able to say to some degree what is
going on with Clara
fine cool so that eliminates a whole
thread of fan theorizing fine but why
did you have to reassert that again it's
such a cool core concept trapped inside
the TARDIS while it's going haywire
so much potential for that and the set
up is solid so it's not
would you like just the core concept and
then they ruined it cuz honestly I can
look at something even like love and
monsters and get to the true original
seed of that idea and go that's an idea
worth trying but as soon as they had
just the premise that they built around
that core it already started to fall
apart the initial premise the setup of
this is even still solid it's not until
the story actually starts moving on that
just falls apart oh and also Clara finds
this book on the time war that in finds
something about the doctor implied to be
his name but again what was the point of
that our Clara's not gonna remember so
there's no payoff to that either I
suppose it serves as a reminder and a
plant for the doctor's name the
important because that'll come back but
in functionally that's more wasted time
there's so much time wasted on stuff
that doesn't matter
both doesn't matter to the episode in
and of itself and doesn't matter to the
overall story but time is spent on it
this is the kind of thing where like I
almost wish that somebody would remake
this would go back do another pass at
the script clean it up get rid of stupid
twist get rid of the monsters and just
give it a cleaner shot cuz yeah it was
solid and it was good even for about
half of it and then just the things that
fell apart fell apart hard
so that's journey to the centre of the
TARDIS you rewashed it lately what are
your thoughts on it whatever they are
drop something on down in the comments
let's talk about it all the usual stuff
- do you know what it is but I'm not
gonna make you do it cuz end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed this I would encourage you to
like and subscribe and share or maybe
hit the bell or also if you're in a
particularly generous mood check on for
a link on my patreon at either the end
of this video or down in the description
give it a look it's incredibly helpful
but you know no pressure or anything
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]